GILBERT STRANG: OK,
so I was speaking
about eigenvalues
and eigenvectors
for a square matrix.
And then I said for data
for many other applications,
the matrices are not square.
We need something that replaces
eigenvalues and eigenvectors.
And what they are--
and it's perfect-- is singular
values and singular vectors.
So may I explain singular
values and singular vectors?
This slide shows a lot of them.
The point is that
there will be--
now I don't say eigenvectors--
two-- different left singular
vectors.
They will go into this matrix u.
Right singular vectors
will go into v.
It was the other case
that was so special.
When the matrix was
symmetric, then the left
equals left eigenvector.
They're the same
as the right one.
That's sort of sensible.
But a general
matrix and certainly
a rectangular matrix--
well, we don't call
them eigenvectors,
because that would
be confusing-- we
call them singular vectors.
And then, inbetween
are not eigenvalues,
but singular values.
Oh, right.
Oh, hiding over here is a key.
A times the v's gives
sigma times the u's.
So that's the replacement
for ax equal lambda
x, which had x on both sides.
OK, now we've got two.
But the beauty is now we've
got two of those to work with.
We can make all the u's
orthogonal to each other--
all the v's orthogonal
to each other.
We can do what only
symmetric matrices
could do for eigenvectors.
We can do it now
for all matrices,
not even squares, just
this is where life is, OK.
And these numbers
instead of the lambdas
are called singular values.
And we use the letter
sigma for those.
And here is a picture of
the geometry in 2 by 2
if we had a 2 by 2 matrix.
So you remember,
factorization breaks
up a matrix into
separate small parts,
each doing its own thing.
So if I multiply by
vector x, the first thing
that's going to hit
it is v transpose.
V transpose is an
orthogonal matrix.
Remember, I said we can
make these singular vectors
perpendicular.
That's what an orthogonal
matrix-- so it's just
like a rotation that you see.
So the v transpose is just
turns the vector to get here
to get to the second one.
Then I'm multiplying
by the lambdas.
But they're not lambdas now.
They're sigma.
The matrix, so
that's capital sigma.
So there is sigma 1 and sigma 2.
What they do is
stretch the circle.
It's a diagonal matrix.
So it doesn't turn things.
But it stretches the
circle to an ellipse
because it gets the two
different singular values
in-- sigma 1 and sigma 2.
And then the last guy, the
u is going to hit last.
It takes the ellipse
and turns out again.
It's again a rotation--
rotation, stretch, rotation.
I'll say it again--
That's what singular
values and singular
vectors do, the singular
value decomposition.
And it's got the best
of all worlds here.
It's got the rotations,
the orthogonal matrices.
And it's got the stretches,
the diagonal matrices.
Compared to those two,
those are the greatest.
Triangular matrices were good
when we were young an hour ago.
Now, we're seeing the best.
OK, now let me just show
you where they come from.
Oh, so how to find these v's.
Well, the answer is, if I'm
looking for orthogonal vectors,
the great idea is find
a symmetric matrix
and with those eigenvectors.
So these v's that I want for
A are actually eigenvectors
of this symmetric
matrix A transpose times
A. That's just nice.
So we can find those
singular vectors
just as fast as we
can find eigenvectors
for a symmetric matrix.
And we know there, because
A transpose A is symmetric.
We know the eigenvectors
are perpendicular
to each other orthonormal.
OK, and now what about the
other ones because remember,
we have two sets.
The u's-- well, we just multiply
by A. And we've got the u's.
Well, and divide by sigmas,
because these vectors u's
and v's are unit
vectors, length one.
So we have to scale
them properly.
And this was a little key
bit of algebra to check that,
not only the v's
were orthogonal,
but the u's are orthogonal.
Yeah, it just comes out--
comes out.
So this singular
value decomposition,
which is maybe, well, say 100
years old, maybe a bit more.
But it's really in the last 20,
30 years that singular values
have become so important.
This is the best
factorization of them all.
And that's not always reflected
in linear algebra courses.
So part of my goal today is
to say get to singular values.
If you've done symmetric
matrices and their eigenvalues,
then you can do singular values.
And I think that's absolutely
worth doing, OK, yeah,
so and remembering down here
that capital Sigma stands
for the diagonal matrix of
these positive numbers, sigma 1,
sigma 2 down to sigma r there.
The rank, which came way
back in the first slides,
tells you how many there are.
Good, good.
Oh, here's an example.
So I took a small
matrix because I'm
doing this by pencil and
paper and actually showing you
that the singular value.
So there is my matrix, 2 by 2.
Here are the u's.
Do you see that those
are orthogonal--
1, 3 against minus 3, 1?
Take the dot product,
and you get 0.
The v's are orthogonal.
The sigma is diagonal.
And then the pieces from
that add back to the matrix.
So it's really, it's
broken my matrix
into a couple of pieces--
one for the first
singular value in vector,
and the other for the second
singular value in vector.
And that's what
data science wants.
Data science wants to know
what's important in the matrix?
Well, what's important
is sigma 1, the big guy.
Sigma 2, you see.
Well, it was 3 times smaller--
3/2 versus 1/2.
So if I had a 100 by 100
matrix or 100 by 1,000,
I'd have 100 singular values and
maybe the first five I'd keep.
If I'm in the financial
market, those guys,
those first numbers
are telling me
maybe what bond prices
are going to do over time.
And it's a mixture
of a few features,
but not all 1,000
features, right.
So this is singular
value decomposition
picks out the important
part of a data matrix.
And you cannot ask
for a more than that.
Here's what you do with a matrix
is just totally enormous--
too big to multiply--
too big to compute.
Then you randomly sample it.
Yeah, maybe the next
slide even mentions
that word randomized
numerical linear algebra.
So this, I'll go back to this.
So the singular
value decomposition--
this, what we just talked
about with the u's and the v's
and the sigmas.
Sigma 1 is the biggest.
Sigma r is the smallest.
So in data science,
you very often
keep just these first ones,
maybe the first k, the k
largest ones.
And then you've
got the matrix that
has rank only k, because you're
only working with k vectors.
And it turns out that's the
closest one to the big matrix
A. So this singular value
is among other things
is picking out, putting
in order of importance
the little pieces of the matrix.
And then you can just pick
a few pieces to work with.
Yeah, yeah.
And the idea of norms is how to
measure the size of a matrix.
Yeah, but I'll leave
that for the future.
And randomized linear algebra
I just want to mention.
Seems a little crazy that
by just randomly sampling
a matrix, we could
learn anything about it.
But typically data
is sort of organized.
It's not just
totally random stuff.
So if we want to know like, my
friend in the Broad Institute
was doing the ancient
history of man.
So data from thousands
of years ago.
So he had a giant matrix--
a lot of data-- too much data.
And he said, how can we find the
singular value decomposition?
Pick out the important thing.
So you had to sample the data.
Statistics is a beautiful
important subject.
And it leans on linear algebra.
Data science leans
on linear algebra.
You are seeing the tool.
Calculus would be functions
would be continuous curves.
Linear algebra is about vectors.
This is just n components.
And that's where you compute.
And that's where you understand.
OK.
Oh, this is maybe the
last slide to just
help orient you in the courses.
So at MIT 18.06 is the
Linear Algebra Course.
And maybe you know
18.06 and also
18.06 Scholar, SC,
on OpenCourseWare.
And then this is the new course
with the new book, 18.065.
So its numbers sort of
indicating a second course
in linear algebra.
That's when I'm
actually teaching now,
Monday, Wednesday, Friday.
And so that starts
with linear algebra,
but it's mostly
about deep learning--
learning from data.
So you need statistics.
You need optimization,
minimizing.
Big functions of
calculus comes into it.
So that's a lot of fun
to teach and to learn.
And, of course,
it's tremendously
important in industry now.
And Google and Facebook
and ever so many companies
need people who understand this.
And, oh, and then I
am repeating 18.06
because there is this
new book coming, I hope.
Did some more this morning.
Linear Algebra for Everyone.
So I have
optimistically put 2021.
And you're the first
people that know about it.
So these are the websites
for the two that we have.
That's the website
for the linear algebra
book, math.mit.edu.
And this is the website for
the Learning from Data book.
So you see there the table of
contents and all and solutions
to problems-- lots of things.
Thanks for listening
to this is--
what-- maybe four or five
pieces in this 2020 vision
to update the videos
that have been watched
so much on OpenCourseWare.
Thank you.